this is true every now and then we do a
lot of sketches on this show a lot of
silly sketches and a lot of times when I
do these sketches it involves me having
to fight somebody we do a lot of
sketches where there has to be like a
fake fight and it always looks
incredibly lame
it always looks really fake it would be
better if the sketch you know looked
realistic if it looked like I was really
fighting so I decided to do something
about it something that a lot of actors
do
I took a stage combat class there's
actually something called stage combat
where you learn to do all that cool fake
fighting and everything and I took it
from an expert a guy who trained at the
Royal Shakespeare Company and I took a I
took a camera crew with me so I thought
it might be interesting and it was
here's what happened I'm standing here
with BH Barre it's correct who is master
of stage combat correct what's the most
recent Broadway show that you have done
stage combat well I'm working at the
moment on chitty-chitty bang-bang
that's the bit you feel that within a
few hours you could teach me the
essentials absolutely yeah that's a
fairly athletic person good oh and my
body what do you think are there's
tremendous ok well then this is your
starting weight head Grayson you coming
below holding load of equipment like a
shower together in real life whenever
I've been in a fight mhmmm I go to
kicking very quickly kicking and
scratching hit and scratch and sometimes
slap good idea and I shriek a lot oh you
do this is our space yeah show me how
you throw a punch
I can hold my hand don't just show me
how you throw a punch and come right
across like that man yeah and you know
that's call I call that bringing the
hammer down after that it's lights out
eight hours of sleep
good good quote again good now leave
your head back cause you do it keep your
head off my head going on it's all the
clapping and snapping I'm doing speed
right up there now can I do this can I
get my fist first yes and then tonight
is it okay if I go I'm good luck yes
voice good be doing this and I didn't
give it a little airline ticket no
kicking there's a little different yes
okay you know why why is that
hitting's the hand I've got kicking the
leg they kick in the crime yes my
shoulders beat you back okay bring your
foot water massage and apply at the back
here and really make it land you can
make it land okay so what I'm doing what
is unplugging everything up
[Applause]
consign you I'm still thinking about
that okay tonight's alright good now my
foot comes in okay next you did hit my
penis just so you know my hands about
here gets interesting
haha these are swords so they'll get a
sword no look at the sword don't see the
swords no the sword the sword is there
be the sword be aware
[Laughter]
yes FEX hope you don't mind I brought
lightsabers motrin right and we also
need the sound Vader so I hear let me
show you these two guys what oh wow yeah
I'm crazy you know what how fortunate
that he threw him onto this cushion oh
yes
what's call this showdown at cushion
town did you want to try and do it for
yeah yeah what's a fall I could do I've
never seen that in any kind of action
adventure I think there's nothing
funnier than a laughing guy who gets his
head smashed into a chair maybe that's
just me so I can actually be punch and
sail through this brick wall okay
[Applause]
now why don't you transfer to combine
these elements this is your secret lair
and sanobim Mexican restaurant so
showdown at Chi Chi's
[Music]
we were who they were because we in the
rainbow azeris
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
what's the time folks better break great
show tonight debut two companies here